Marvel's back and this time Spider-Man
and Thor are fighting a whale the MCU is
really falling off the movie opens up in
1850 when an author named Herman
Melville arrives at Nantucket Island the
purpose of his visit is to meet an old
inkeeper named Thomas Nickerson the last
survivor of the sinking of the whale
ship Essex when Herman knocks on the
door Thomas's wife thinking he's a
customer says that they're closed
however Herman shows her a letter and
introduces himself self eventually
gaining access following this he goes to
Thomas and expresses his wish to hear
the story of Essex but the old man
refuses to talk to convince him Herman
offers all the money in his wallet in
return for the story but to no avail
he's only got three deons and two
schmeck alls anyway instead Thomas makes
some mean remarks asking him to leave
feeling humiliated the author tries to
leave but Thomas's wife stops him she
apologizes on behalf of her husband and
requests him to to wait for a while she
then goes to talk to her husband and
reminds him of how they're struggling
financially they need the schmeckles at
last Thomas agrees to the request of his
wife he tells Herman that he'll share
the story for as long as he can bear it
following this the movie takes us back
to 1820 the time when whale hunting was
prevalent people used to hunt down
whales and extract their oil the oil was
so rare that people would trade as well
as gamble for it we are introduced to a
n Tucket farmer and Whaler named Owen
Chase who is happily married to a woman
named Peggy Owen works for a wailing
company and one day he excitedly goes to
meet his Superior Executives who have
promised to hire him as the captain for
their new ship you guessed it Essex
however his excitement Fades away when
he learns that the executives have
reconsidered their decision and have
demoted him to first mate instead they
have hired George polard as the captain
who is an inexperienced Mariner from an
established wailing family Owen is
clearly upset by this and decides to
walk away but they promise to provide
him the captaincy next time they also
increase his wage in an attempt to
convince him Owen agrees on the
condition that they sign a written
contract promising the captaincy the
next day he gets ready for his year-long
whale Hunting Expedition but his wife
appears concerned before he leaves she
hands him her locket making him promise
that he'll return home safe later that
day all the Whalers gather at the ship
dock to watch a group set off on Essex a
14 y- old Thomas is also in the same
ship working as one of the cabin boys as
the Ship Sails off Captain George starts
ordering his Juniors causing a minor
Rift between them a short while later
there seems to be a problem the ship's
sail becomes stuck causing it to start
losing its balance seeing this Owen
takes the matter in his own hands and
professionally climbs up a mast to
unfurl the sail George who is
inexperienced feels a twitch of Envy
upon witnessing his skills as a result
he takes his revenge venge on the dining
table that night George makes some mean
remarks about Owen and his father which
infuriates the latter however he can't
fight back with the captain so he leaves
the table abruptly feeling humiliated
from the next day on George again starts
to give orders to Owen who has no choice
but to cooperate the poop deck is almost
certainly involved at one point Owen
Witnesses a sea storm approaching
towards them he hurriedly shares this
with the captain and suggests that they
change their ship's Direction however
George disre guards his advice and
decides to move forward soon after the
storm hits the ship damaging it badly
while in the middle of the storm the
captain orders that they retreat but
Owen claims that it's already too late
and urges the people to hold on
thankfully the people in the ship manag
to hold on and save their lives after
surviving the storm George shares his
decision to return back to Nantucket
Island to repair the ship he also ask so
to write an apology letter mentioning
that he didn't follow the captain's
orders and endangered the crew's life
This enrages Owen who finally speaks up
claiming that it was George's decision
to sail into the storm and risk the crew
in response The Arrogant Captain yells
at Owen urging him not to cross his
boundary he also starts boasting about
his family's historical reputation after
a while of heated discussion the two
eventually agree to put their
differences aside and work together the
seen them fast forwards 3 months and
Essex is now in the middle of the sea at
this point they finally locate a large
number of whales swimming nearby without
wasting any time they board their
whaling boats and sail towards the
majestic creatures to hunt them down
upon approaching them Owen harpoons a
sperm whale causing it to dive deep into
the sea the crew waits for the whale to
die but it continues to swim downward as
their ropes start running out the crew
suggests cutting it Loose to avoid being
dragged down despite This Owen insists
on waiting and his Insight pays off when
the whale dies just before they run out
of of rope following this they tow the
whale towards the ship and initiate the
oil extraction process however the
opening in the whale's head isn't big
enough which creates difficulty in the
extraction process as a result Thomas
being the youngest and smallest among
the crew and because it's a sperm whale
and Thomas can shoot sperm out of his
wrists is tasked with entering the
whale's head to scoop out the remaining
oil several months pass since their
first hunt and no more whales appear for
the Essex the biggest problem is that
they're running out of their food George
realizes that the Atlantic Ocean holds
no sighting of whales and as a result
the Essex sails past Cape Horn to the
Pacific hoping for better luck in
Catching one after a very long journey
they arrive at atacames Ecuador
butchered that there they meet with a
Spanish Captain who tells them that his
crew found the Bountiful offshore
grounds 2,000 mil to the west but he
also reveals that a vengeful enormous
white whale destroyed his ship killing
six of his men regardless George and
Owen dismissed the story as a myth and
lead the Expedition Westward exactly 14
months pass when they arrive at offshore
ground situated in the heart of the sea
just as the Spanish Captain said the
Essex crew finds a pot of whales the
crew is very happy and excited thinking
that they can extract as much oil as
they need and return home they instantly
launch their wailing boats and sail in
the direction of the whales but as they
prepare to begin the hunt a massive
sperm whale with white scarred skin
attacks Owen's boat flipping it upside
down following This Owen and his team
swim back to Essex and start repairing
their boat quickly amidst this the white
whale suddenly attacks the Essex causing
water to leak from the base this sends
the crew into a state of panic however
Owen is still adamant on hunting this
white whale so he doubles the Harpoon
and hurls it towards it the Harpoon hits
the target right on point and the whale
starts swimming down soon after the Rope
which is tied to the Mast runs out due
to which the entire ship begins to
collapse as a consequence the harpoons
penetrating the whale's body also detach
freeing it again now with the Essex
sinking at a rapid Pace the crew decides
to abandon it they hurriedly grab as
much food supplies as they can and get
on the three intact whaling boats just
then the whale oil the crew had gathered
earlier catches fire causing the entire
ship to explode now the crew must sail
hundreds of miles to shore with very
limited supplies the following morning
they analyzed the Sea map and set off
towards their tough Journey a few days
pass by and they are again hit by a sea
storm the storm is so powerful that one
of the crew members named Matthew who is
also Owen's childhood friend gets
injured the crew manages to survive the
storm and continues their Journey but as
the weeks pass by they grow extremely
tired and are forced to survive with a
mere piece piece of biscuit as their
daily food despite this harsh situation
Owen takes care of his injured friend
but the rest of the members consider
Matthew to be a burden a burden that
they want to eat after 34 days of being
stranded they finally spot an island
lifting their Spirits filled with a new
sense of hope they all sail towards the
same as they are about to approach the
shore Owen senses something a miss and
he instructs everyone to stop it turns
out to be the same white whale that has
been following them from the very
beginning the whale launches another
attack on the crew members destroying
their boats and throwing them into the
water some of the crew members are
killed some drown While others wash
ashore on the island as soon as they
reach the island they devour any edible
things available such as raw fish and
bird eggs later that night they Camp
inside a small tunnel on the island they
also ignite a fire hoping to catch the
attention of any passing ships however
even after several weeks no one comes to
their rescue one day while searching for
food Owen discovers some dead bodies of
earlier Castaways in a cave this makes
him realize that help may never arrive
and they might end up with the same fate
Owen then urges the crew members to
leave as they might die waiting on this
island before another ship passes by
following this they start repairing
their damaged boat to leave the place on
the day of departure everyone agrees to
leave except for four men including the
injured Matthew who have given up even
though there is very little hope Owen
promises to send a rescue team once he
reaches home after this he and the rest
of the crew members sail off on their
boats on the 48th day of being stranded
one of the crew members dies on the boat
out of starvation the others decide to
wrap the body and cast it into the sea
but Owen intervenes he tells them not to
throw away something that can keep them
alive the members are shocked by this
idea but they are forced to cannibalize
him for their survival this harsh and
Grim moment breaks the young Thomas in
into tears in the present the older
Thomas is overcome with remorse for his
cannibalism and stops his story Herman
deeply moved by the story asks if Thomas
has told anyone about it Thomas admits
he hasn't even shared it with his wife
fearing that she might not love him for
what he did at that very moment his wife
who has been secretly listening to the
story walks in and reassures that she
still loves him she too likes the taste
of weenus this encourages Thomas to
finish the rest of his story back to the
past the crew members have been stranded
for 71 days the three boats are now
separated by the currents and
unfortunately one is lost the situation
is deteriorated to the point that the
men in George's boat even draw straws to
determine who should be sacrificed for
their next meal one day the white whale
shows up one more time and Owen gets
into position for a final attack the
whale breaches for a moment allowing
Owen to see a portion of his previously
thrown Harpoon still embedded above the
whale's eye Owen hesitates and stares
into the whale's left eye as the
creature stares back at him if Owen is
imagining himself to be this thing's
equal he's a goddamn idiot Owen then
lowers his Harpoon deciding not to kill
the whale following this encounter The
Majestic white whale swims away
peacefully and is never seen again after
a few more days a passing ship spots
George's boat and they are rescued
meanwhile Owen's boat continues to drift
with no food or water the survivors are
on the verge of death when their boat
thankfully reaches one of the islands in
Chile from there the survivors are
rescued and brought back to Nantucket
where they finally reunite with their
distressed families but before the
survivors return home they are summoned
by The Nantucket ship's owners to
discuss the incident the executives
asked George and Owen to cover up the
story to protect the industry's
reputation however Owen refuses claiming
that it would be unfair to dismiss what
the crew had gone through having enough
of their dishonesty Owen resigns and
leaves that day the young Thomas meets
Owen one last time and the latter hands
him a whalebone pin before departing the
following day at the court George who is
motivated by Owen's words reveals the
truth much to the executives anger back
in the present Thomas says that Owen
being a man of his word sent a ship to
rescue the surviving men in the earlier
Island regrettably Matthew had already
passed away but the team successfully
rescued the other three survivors
according to Thomas Owen then continued
sailing the Seas and became a merchant
Captain while George carried out another
failed attempt to find and kill the
whale after hearing the entire story
Herman expresses gratitude to Thomas
acknowledging that he has learned a new
lesson cannibalism uh uh courage in the
final scene we see that Herman has
completed his novel by the name of Mobi
dick which became a biggest hit in
America probably because dick was in the
title subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching